in good shape your weekly dose of health
information on deutsche welle find out
more about what's new in medical
treatment alternative medicine as well
as nutrition wellness and beauty medical
professionals therapists and counselors
are in our studio to offer their expert
advice on in good shape a big welcome to
Claudius could edit your sports
scientist and health codes based here in
Berlin welcome to hello check hi
meditative running combines a garden
variety of jogging with the principles
of awareness how does this help your
health of course just like with jogging
you have all the positive effects of a
cardiovascular training like the
reduction of muscle tension like the
reduction of fatty acids in your blood
and the reduction of stress hormones
like cortisol and adrenaline but
furthermore it helps to interrupt the
steady thinking of your mind so you calm
down with your mind very easily so it's
both it's a body and a psychological
work out it's the optimal work out to
that works on the level of body and mind
and when we say something you would use
this stress what does this mean for the
body and the body you build up over the
day is stress hormones like cortisol and
adrenaline and this works like that so
your blood pressure goes up and you have
tension in your body and after a long
working day you need to get rid of this
tension again and you can do that very
effectively by the combination of
running and a mindfulness-based
meditation so you reduce the cholesterol
in your blood and you get calm and
relaxed so this seems to be the the
wonderful so can everybody do meditative
jogging or rather some people are some
patients you wouldn't recommend it to if
you are overweight or you have
cardiovascular problems already you
should talk to your physician first
maybe you can start with meditative
walking which is much softer
than meditative running and what can you
take from this form of workout into your
daily life when you do meditative
running you are very busy perceiving
your body signals so this will transfer
to daily life and you will be able to
perceive when it's time to make a break
during the working hours as so you stay
fit for a long time and you don't burn
out so it's listening to your body but
if you don't like to jog or don't even
like to power walk or meditative work
are there any other exercise you can do
with a meditative state of mind you can
also do tai chi or yoga or chi gong this
is also the combination of meditation
and activity and exercise is generally
considered one of to be one of the best
forms of stress reduction why is that
usually your body as human being you
meant to live a physically active life
because you're meant to be a hunter or
genetics are like the genetics of
hunting so if you are at work and you
have a challenge then your body responds
just like like when lie on the stand
standing in front of you so your muscle
tension builds up your breath blood
pressure goes up and all that prepares
you for physical activity if you don't
give your body the chance give away to
physical activity this this higher
alertness of your body will persist and
that's not very healthy because you
cannot get back brain problems high
blood pressure and cardiovascular
diseases so you need the exercise and
you need to change between exercise and
relaxation to really live a balanced
life mr. cooter that boxing is
considered a very good fitness training
why is that for boxing you need to speak
you need engines you need power you need
flexibility and mobility and you need
the capability of focusing very well and
in a boxing training you learn all that
so boxing
training is very effective to change
your body to make it to enhance your
fitness that's why boxing training is
also used in lots of fitness classes so
it's a whole body workout them yeah and
and they're different kind of boxing
like competitive boxing with a partner
or more like fitness boxing with the
punching ball which is best for stress
reduction if you go for stress reduction
fitness boxing is the optimal away
because do you have no risk of injury
and the effect on your body fitness is
the same like with real boxing but but
what about self-confidence boxing
usually should raise and improve
yourself confidence with a punching ball
as well or just with a partner when you
train people like I did at boxing you
realize that they will realize that they
have a tremendous amount of power they
didn't know about once their pungent
their the heavy back and see it moving
they're amazed how much power they
possess and this is very good for a self
confidence and your self esteem and even
with the punching bag and we got to
review a question from kidada Susannah
Eisenberg from Canada wrote in hello in
good shape if you have a disc injury in
the upper part of the spine can you
train with a punching bag what's it
about slipped disc is it dangerous to do
a boxing training if you are in acute
pain because of that slip dist then you
shouldn't rain but a disc injury can
heal and once it's healed maybe the
flexibility of your spine is a little
bit you reduced but actually you can
train everything but go to your
physician and ask him whether you're in
the state that you can box or if you
should rest until it's healed completely
and some people say boxing is a sport
for tough min what about women it's okay
for women too isn't it it's brilliant
for women and especially because I
experience that when women come to me to
the boxing training and they don't they
don't want to unleash all their power
and their aggression because because of
socialization there maybe maybe they
don't feel female they do that but once
they realize that
they have a potential they didn't know
about this amount of power within their
body this is really very good for
women's confidence and that's why I can
really advise boxing for women and if
people say no no way boxing is not for
me any other spot any other martial arts
which are good for stress reduction judo
karate and also wrestling they have a
very nice effect on your body as a whole
fitness workout and at the same time
they have to get rid of stress and then
some exercises you shouldn't do to
reduce stress when it's very competitive
then stress can add to your spare time
if you go for if you have to be the
first in a run or if you have to win
against somebody like a table tennis
playing one-on-one if you lose it might
not feel very good and it brings you on
the tension so keep it on a fitness
level it's always should be fun thank
you cloud is good at it thanks for being
at this video you're welcome
you